I'm still trying to find out my purpose
what is your purpose I'm a witch a model
amused an actress a dancer artist
and my own personal creation personally
witchcraft at this point because it
feels necessary to stay up so the
purpose is witchcraft modeling and or
Model news within my own little circle
of life I want to Aspire it to creating
something my block is that I'm not in
society right now I'm literally like um
what do you call them
um like a Hermit you know what I mean
I'm living alone so when you grow up
what you want to be model
model creative director fashion creative
director and or Muse you're right I'm
still young so you think like I've ate
my trap you're gonna have aged out you
know and your drug habit isn't getting
in the way of it my all fashion does is
drugs Mark fashion is drugs okay Versace
cocaine came off cocaine
chat Monk what would I leave to go mice
has literally did lines of Molly at a
[__] concert I actually have a Robert
Downey Jr oh you met him I like him yeah
he used to do drugs there you come down
here back in the day yeah yeah we're
gonna kidnap him but he left before they
were gonna get him yeah he was on drugs
how old are you